hey uh mr dillon uh huge
fan mr vaughn long time long time
listener watcher first time caller and
communicator
pardon my back mullet i don't have a top
mullet but i got a little back hair i'm
gonna let that heat go anyway i got a
crazy question from mr dylan what do you
think about the assassin
killing himself that shot the judge's
son
this just elaine maxwell shit's getting
a little trash yeah it's real creepy
yeah so let's get into that first let's
just establish that
epstein you believe epstein was a
pedophile
i'm just saying let's just establish
some great what are you working for
wait a minute hold on what
yes i will take a controversial stance
because i believe epstein is a pedophile
okay you heard it here okay and you
think geese lane was his little
is uh his his runner yeah i think that's
pretty well established i think miss
maxwell was involved in some alert and
inappropriate activities
but as trump would say i wish her well
yeah cause that's the way rich people
talk
rich people every now and then rich
people just
become rich and they forget that they
have a job he forgot he was the
president yeah he was
i had a golf tee on mar-a-lago in his
mind and he said what he would have said
to some ceo that was next to me yeah i
wish her well
because that's when you're like yeah my
son he got into it underage real big
problem because i wish him well
i'm well yeah and just you know watch
this drive it's so different people
don't understand also yeah that rich
mindset of them they don't get
it like it's just niceties and
politeness like gizlane got busted
having a couple of chocolates she
shouldn't have had you know yeah
they're just they're just like yeah i
wish her well hey man just
get out of my get out of my world
with your problems i'm rich i want to be
rich just lane is rich
so i wish her well if just lane wasn't
rich it would be like
f burner i don't care put her in a room
and light her up but
because she's rich i don't want to see a
member of my own class
really bite the bullet so i wish her
well i hope she has to write a long
apology letter to the girls
and they put her back on a boat but yeah
this assassin was super weird
um the judge it was assigned to look
into the money laundering at deutsche
bank so a bunch of investors at george
bank were like hey why are you letting
jeffrey epstein and all these people why
are you tolerating all these high-risk
clients right so a bunch of investors at
twitch bank got mad at this and deutsche
bank should have just sent out a letter
went shut the [ __ ] up
right we do what we want we're criminals
dummy what do you think goes on here
we launder drug money and everything
else we got narco traffickers human
traffickers shut the [ __ ] up
you didn't care when you were returned
you only care because it's the goddamn
news
cliff they should like if you're like
like hit him with a first name
first name you know listen vance you
know what's going on
shut the [ __ ] up um so
but so there were some banks so there's
some investors i don't know all about it
so there's some investors
yeah and the they were all working with
the same a lot of shady people working
with the same bank yeah deutsche bank
okay and they're
deutsche bank's like a lot of their
executives end up killing themselves in
malibu it's super suspect because
people in malibu don't kill themselves
they're happy right like they killed
themselves
so this idea that all these people in
malibu are like i just
can't do another day in the sun i gotta
kill myself
deutsche bank's involved in some weird
stuff so deutsche bank and what is the
deutsch it's what
german okay yeah so they uh are handling
high-risk clients like jeffrey epstein
okay and a bunch of investors like hey
why are you what are you doing here why
are you tolerating this level of risk
blah blah blah so they bring a class
action suit against twitch bank
a judge gets assigned that suit four
days later
her son and her husband a guy shows up
in a fedex suit her son and her husband
end up getting killed or her husband's
not dead he's critically wounded her son
is dead
and then the guy who does this goes and
kills himself about an hour and a half
later
now supposedly this guy this guy named
roy hollander was a men's rights
activist
who had actually called an opie anthony
and like argued with jim norton
he's like a weird guy and he was the
fedex driver he was just yeah
dressed up in a fedex outfit he was fake
fedex fake fat actor was he in this a
regular vehicle
i imagine yeah oh my gosh so then he
just has a giveaway
so what people are what i am a little
suspicious about is i'm like
is this guy actually the guy who did it
is this guy
did he do it but did somebody like put
him up to it right because this
you know this is a crazy coincidence
that
this woman's child is now dead because
that is a crazy way to send a message
right like because you're telling all
the old judges like hey you might want
to gamble with your life we'll kill your
kids
right like we'll just kill everyone you
know like it is a crazy message
um and it makes you think about anytime
somebody kills themselves they can't be
asked any questions
i get real like wait a minute hold on
what happened so it's entirely possible
that this was some type of threat
or you know a way to intimidate or scare
people that are in the case i don't know
it's also possible that this guy's just
a crazy guy that killed the judge i
don't know but
it's worth looking into have has the
judge responded after the killing
has a judge spoken man suspected
i mean this is tragic 20 year old kid oh
it's heartbreaking
and he was just at home doing what it's
weird the guys of men's rights act as he
killed two men
i'm like that's makes me start thinking
like wait a minute what
that's odd but it's also interesting a
good place to go look for someone who
would do something like this
is someone who repeatedly calls into a
radio show but here's the thing the
people that want this done know that
right they know that of course they're
like this is where we find crazy people
they know where to get the fun people
yeah
this guy also 20 years ago worked for
kroll securities which is like an
intelligent corporate espionage
intelligence
gathering uh major corporation he worked
for a year in russia
handling uh intelligence gathering for
kroll so it's just odd
very lee harvey oswald yeah it's a very
weird like background for the guy to
have
you know here's a guy right here who has
an issue and this guy
i have a few issues yeah what's going on
my name is miles
tim i saw you at the stress factory in
bridgeport connecticut
and you said that i look like i traffic
children because i was wearing a suit
so two questions one would you like to
retract that statement
and two do you think glenn is gonna make
it to trial
uh i don't yeah number one let me
retract that statement because now you
look like a dirtbag who can't afford
anything
uh you should have kept the suit on well
he does have a frisbee collection behind
him yeah
now you look like you now you look like
you traffic pizzas to people's homes for
a living
so that's what you look like now you
look like you're trafficking for papa
john's
trafficking bread sticks to poor people
um
uh it will glaine make it to trial i
mean i mean
not if a lot of powerful people have
something to say about it
do you think i mean do you think a lot
of people
really were into this type of thing like
they would fly over there to have sex
with
enough yeah i think enough people yeah i
think it was a way to blackmail people
so
powerful people go over there they do
this stuff you get them on camera
you own them and control them forever
yeah so if you're an intelligence agency
or whatever
even you know a billionaire that wants
to control
senators or congressmen or whatever
because you don't want the passing laws
that [ __ ] with your money
it's just it's a foolproof way to be
like yeah oh you're going to vote that
way how about this and then they go
yeah i guess you're right so in the end
do you think that epstein's
biggest problem was or not obviously he
had a lot of problems but do you think
that one of the underlying issues of all
of his problems was
more like control it was like how do i
yes it was all about like manipulating
people you're absolutely right it was
how do we control people and epstein was
just
a facilitator for bigger forces that are
looking to control people wow
and that's part of what happens you know
i mean i'm sure listen
there's reasons in hollywood that the
same actors get the same roles
all the time and a lot of them are very
talented but i think a lot of it is that
they have very powerful agents and
people that are able to like
get make things happen right how do you
make things happen you need leverage how
do you get leverage well leverage is
information yeah right it's information
that's technically kind of what leverage
is it's like
i know that's a prime ingredient yeah so
i mean it's it's it's entirely possible
that like
this is just the way things have been
run for so long
and now it's coming to light because you
have the internet and you
have people back then victims couldn't
talk to each other
so one girl that had a crazy experience
couldn't email another girl and go hey
did this happen to you
right yeah that's like the only positive
thing from it good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah